victor yaki can you share with your
audience what you're reading
to prepare for specific upcoming videos
i think it would help a previously
unstudied but curious mind like my own
learn
even more
so let's say i have an interview coming
up i look up the person's corpus usually
it's a person rather than a
group of people and then i see what
interviews they've done what academic
articles they've published i may sort
that by most cited or most interesting
to myself
i make a note of any relevant other
infos like books they may have written
or articles written about them i try to
read
enough of
other people's commentary as well as
their own commentary on their work to
get an understanding of their point of
view i may do a
podcast on what it takes to prepare for
a tow podcast
i may do not a podcast maybe a video
let's say
and if people are interested let me know
step up startup enjoy your time away
what i find super fascinating about you
is your pause moments
in
pause moments
how in the heat of the conversation
you're able to do it and analyze and
come back with a very authentic point
instead of getting lost or taken away
you must be mentally drained afterward
because it takes plenty of energy on
that subject do you take any supplements
for focus or have a diet i know you
mentioned that you don't eat
before your conversations
so for supplements
for focus no
i've
tried virtually every nootropic that
exists and i don't find any of them
works for me except for caffeine and
venobut however
the latter i take perhaps maybe once
every two months or even less because i
am terribly
afraid of getting addicted to any of
these supplements or substances as for
fasting i almost never
eat prior to a podcast for whatever
reason i feel like it's
cheating it's like me being
a surrent in some manner
and so
i put it off until i have my reward so
it's almost like i feel like the same
feeling that i get if i was to eat my
dessert prior to the salad is the
feeling that i get
that same feeling of
of voraciousness indulging in my own
voraciousness
as
if i was to eat prior to a podcast to me
it's not it's not decorous it's not
correct it's not right i need to do the
podcast and then reward myself with food
and i love
i love food i i
surf it i gorge i gorge myself past the
point of over saturated
sorry past the point of over saturation
i love to eat this one of my i love to
eat with my wife
like i don't like to eat alone i love to
eat with my wife additionally when it
comes to the fasting i don't frequently
fast i intermittently fast virtually
every day but i don't fast for 48 hours
or 72 hours
except perhaps once a month or or once
every two weeks or so
and the reasons for fasting aren't to do
with cognition but instead simply timing
i don't have the time
to eat
i find that
i like to reward myself
by eating
afterwards so i eat just once a day or
twice a day and that's after i've done
the majority of my work if not all of my
work to sum up i'm a glutton
i
i
relish food
and
i i treat it sacredly
fanny ram
how much do you usually prep for a talk
and how much of a free ride do you get
from your educational background
brackets undergrad i
tend to have to relearn almost all of
what i've learned as an undergrad and i
realized that i had mislead it back then
if i've learned it at all
which is why in the crash course on
physics i go through details of how
how i think a particular physical
concept should be thought of or physics
should be taught or mathematics should
be taught and it's
to avoid this the confusion that i had
i was never the type to study in groups
nor ask the professor for help and that
has hindered me greatly because much of
how
people study is in groups if you go to a
university and you see a study group
almost all of their misapprehensions are
settled there whereas for me i don't
have that and i wasn't
i wasn't open enough to talk to other
people when i was in university and i
just feel like i have
virtually no one to talk to so almost
all of me trying to solve my own
non-comprehensions
happen solitarily
so for example one would be how does a
certain league group sit inside another
league group i have to figure that out
on my own by reading and by watching
videos and
it's
extremely painful and protracted as for
how long does it usually take to prepare
i would say about a week per interviewee
so that's six
full days of
work
okay now fanny ram has
a second part to this if you are a
non-math major say engineering how long
would it take for you to get up to speed
with gage theories
that depends heavily on who is teaching
it so if you're lucky enough to have a
great teacher then well it can be
extremely quickly the issue is that as
soon as you've
learned some subject it becomes
extremely
easy to underestimate how arduous it was
to learn that subject to begin with how
difficult the concept is and
one is trying to explain
to a student who has no clue what this
i'm trying to explain i'm trying to do
this vaguely and i i think it would be
better if i gave a concrete example but
hopefully you can understand what i'm
saying when you finally understand
something
you take for granted how difficult it is
to come to that understanding especially
after there's been some time from once
you finally understand it to when you're
teaching it so
many teachers don't see where the
confusions lie for students because
they've forgotten
what it's like to
not understand the concept the
people who are most skilled at
researching aren't necessarily the best
lecturers in fact at the university of
toronto they don't hire based on
lecturing abilities almost at all
they hire based on your ability to
conduct research and advance the field
and those
aren't the same so you can look up the
well you can look up a lecture on yang
mills theory by david gross i think it
was about the yang mills
millennium prize puzzle and you can see
how scattered it is you can also see how
he doesn't write
in any clear manner and that person
david gross is a nobel prize winning
physicist he's at the top of his domain
it's rare that you get individuals like
ed whitton and terry tao who are
masterful at teaching and they're at the
peak of their subject so
to answer the question if you're
studying by yourself then maybe it would
take one year if you're studying under
someone who knows
then maybe it would just take a month